[Music]
all right thank you everyone for coming
to my talk
um my name is Jeremy Wagner and I'm a
technical writer at Google for Chrome
focusing specifically
on web performance and core web vitals
um
I am from Minneapolis Minnesota which if
you don't know where that is
um don't worry about it uh it's it's a
place uh I guess you could say if you
ever see a Minnesotan depicted on a
television show they kind of you know
sound like this don't you know and so
that's really all you need to know we're
kind of a weird remote place and the
further north you go the weirder it gets
um so anywho
I'm honored to be in Seoul my first time
in in not just in Korea but in Asia
which is awesome uh to be giving this
talk about a new responsiveness metric
uh that we've been working on at Google
called interaction to next paint or imp
for short so let's get rolling
so before we can get into imp we need to
clarify responsiveness and when we talk
about responsiveness we're really
talking about how quickly a user
interface responds to a user's input
you've almost certainly experienced poor
responsiveness it occurs when you
interact with something on the page but
the visual feedback of that interaction
is significantly delayed
poor responsiveness makes a page seem
unreliable and this unreliability means
that you may have to tap multiple times
on a page element which can cause
multiple unintended inputs as you can
tell in this video or Worse no response
at all
so we want good responsiveness because
it gives a sense that a page is reliable
in in responding to what we want it to
do
so what causes poor responsiveness to
answer that we need to talk about tasks
in order for a web page to provide a
user experience a web browser must
orchestrate a lot of work to do that it
uses threads there are many threads but
the most important of these is the main
thread it's where most work occurs
including the work your JavaScript code
queues up
hang on
each discrete piece of activity on the
main thread is a task
and a task is made up of activity in
this case we see that this activity
consists of script evaluation and
compilation
now each task takes the amount of time
it requires to complete
however if a task takes too much time it
affects how quickly the main thread can
respond to subsequent tasks and when
that happens that task becomes a long
task
a long task is any task that it seeds
exceeds 50 milliseconds and the portion
of the task longer than 50 milliseconds
is known as the tasks blocking time
which is the amount of time that the
main thread is unable to respond quickly
enough to new tasks this is a
significant source of poor poor input
responsiveness
long tasks can cause pages to be
sluggish and unable to respond quickly
to user inputs
when it's vital to remember that tasks
Drive everything that happens on the
main thread and that includes
interactions here you can see that
there's a single task that shows a
loading spinner as a result of a key
down event
these types of interactions and Far Far
More make up the user and experiences
that we use every day
and those interactions need to be fast
because what we want is visual feedback
sooner and that visual feedback comes in
the form of a new frame that the browser
that the browser paints
hence the name of the metric interaction
to next paint
one way of optimizing work in the
browser is to avoid long tasks too many
long tasks are a user experience problem
but more than that it can also be the
accumulation of many small tasks that
can be problematic as well
in either case the important thing to
remember is that there is also time that
the renderer requires in order to
present the next frame
this involves some tasks that run on the
main thread such as style and layout
calculations maybe even stuff for
request animation frame but there's also
time involved on the GPU and compositor
threads to get the next frame ready to
paint
it's just that long tasks are easier to
identify in profilers
so they're really a great place to start
optimizing
now you might be thinking come on Jeremy
why are we talking so much about tasks
task tasks that's all you're ever
talking about
well the reason for this is the event
Loop which is something I won't go into
deep detail about but it is important to
know just a bit about it uh
and how long tasks or many small tasks
can sabotage the user experience
the event Loop is a continuously looping
task queuing mechanism run by the main
thread it loops around
and around
and around and around it does this until
the task until a task is queued up
and when that happens the event Loop
will pick up the task
a key up event handler in this example
and when the event Loop has has picked
up the task it processes it and it pops
it off the queue when finished
then if the task causes any changes to
the layout the browser has to do
rendering work to reflect those changes
before the next paint
when that rendering work is completed
the browser presents a new frame which
is the visual feedback from the task
if tasks
if tasks don't become long tasks or if
there are a lot of small tasks that pile
up in the queue or aren't a lot of small
tasks to pile up in the queue everything
goes smoothly
but when there is too much work visual
feedback is delayed that stuttering
janky feeling you get when you scroll
and things just aren't working or like
just animations aren't going as fast as
they could be
um and even outright freezing of the
browser Tab and some extreme cases
that's a problem
imp is a metric that quantifies a Page's
ability to avoid doing these things
this will be a quick rundown of how imp
works but for the full story you're
going to want to read the official
documentation at web.dev inp to get a
sense of all the little nooks and
crannies in terms of how it works but
because it is a complex metric and I
only have so much time but I will do my
best to summarize
imp is a metric bat observes certain
interactions using the event timing API
this API receives an entry every time
the user interacts with the page and
contains timings for those interactions
unlike first input delay
imp measures more than just the input
delay of the first interaction if you
don't know what an input delay is don't
worry we'll get there
and finally it chooses the single worst
interaction or close to it which is
intended to represent a Page's overall
interaction latency
it's a bit more complicated than this so
a little bit more on this in a bit
the takeaway from all of this
is that imp is all about the time it
takes for the a new frame to be
presented for the current interaction
from the time the operating system
recognizes an input for the browser to
pick up that input for the event
handlers that drive it to run and
finally for the time it takes the
browser to do all of the rendering work
to show you the results of that work in
the next frame
however imp doesn't measure all
interaction types but it does measure
most that drive user interactions those
include
keyboard interactions
Mouse clicks
and Taps on touch screens
it's also important to call out what
doesn't get taken into account for imp
at least directly
this isn't an exhaustive list but just a
few things that are important to call
out
hovering over elements with a fine
pointer device such as a mouse don't
count towards inp however however
because this is tricky you could trigger
animation work that may affect a soon to
be future interaction think if you hover
over a button that has a hover animation
um if that work is occurring as the user
clicks on the button that may delay the
presentation of the next frame
network activity is in fact isn't
factored into the duration of an event
for inp however fetch requests are
asynchronous and can have an indirect
effect especially if they land during a
future interaction
scrolling isn't taken into account
either however that's no word again
however
users can scroll with the space bar so
if an event captures space bar inputs
that could theoretically cue up tasks
that may affect that interaction but the
scrolling itself is not considered
all qualifying interactions are recorded
throughout the entire life cycle of the
page
when the page is unloaded for a new one
the pages imp is calculated by choosing
one of those interactions
for pages with relatively few
interactions such as pages with mostly
text and images or just simpler
applications with fewer input
requirements this is often the
interaction with the most latency or the
slowest or worst interaction
however
some pages may have many interactions
before they're unloaded such a single
page applications and Rich apps like
in-browser games and other application
types
in such cases we don't want to penalize
developers by selecting what could be an
extreme outlier of interaction latency
in cases like these
the 98th percentile of interaction
latency is selected
the resulting value is the Page's inp
the idea is that by selecting the worst
interaction on the page or closest to it
you have a value that represents a
Page's overall interaction latency think
of it this way if your imp is in the
good range that is 200 milliseconds or
less all interactions on your page are
reliably fast
if your imp needs Improvement or is poor
then it's likely that most of your pages
or at least a decent chunk of them uh
all those interactions are too slow
but what does an interaction look like
the first part of the interaction starts
with the user input from one of the
interaction types we just discussed for
example say a user clicks on a button to
open a menu
when the user clicks there is a period
of time between when the user clicks and
the event handlers begin to run which is
called the input delay this is what
first input delay measures but only for
the first interaction imp measures more
than this it measures the entire
interaction and all qualifying
interactions which you'll see shortly
now you'll always incur some input delay
because at the very least it takes time
for the browser to receive the input
event from the operating system
but that delay can be increased due to
tasks on the main thread as the input
occurs long tasks in particular if you
have a lot of long tasks that are
constantly running on the main thread or
even many small tasks input delays can
increase
once the input delay is over the event
handler is responsible for driving the
interaction can run now here we see a
set of event handlers for a mouse click
the goal here is to ensure that those
handlers run as fast as possible
you don't want those event handlers to
run for too long because the browser has
work to do after that in order to
present the visual feedback the user
needs in order to see that something has
happened
once the event handlers finish running
the browser then needs to do rendering
painting and compositing work in order
to present the next frame this is called
the presentation delay and all this work
to present a new frame to the user needs
to occur as quickly as possible as well
the presentation delay represents just
the main thread portion of the rendering
work there are a lot of nooks and
crannies and how this takes and how long
this takes some of it is under your
control some of it may be
and it gets more complicated a single
interaction can contain multiple input
delays event handlers and present
presentation delays for example here you
see a mouse interaction where a frame is
presented after the user pushes down on
a mouse button but then when the button
is released a new batch of event
handlers and rendering tasks must run in
order to present additional feedback as
the interaction is finished
in cases where there are multiple event
handlers in a single logical user
interaction the longest event duration
of the interaction will be chosen as the
latency for The Logical interaction
now we're ready to talk about how to
optimize for imp
when you optimize imp you're going to
want to First measure it and not just in
lab tools but using field data
field data is important because it lets
you know how your website is actually
being experienced by actual users in the
field and one way to gather that field
data yourself is to use the web vitals
Library which there's a link in the
lower right hand corner to the GitHub
thing and I'm also posting slides on my
Twitter later so if you miss this don't
worry
the library exposes methods for each of
the core web vitals but also inp and
each method takes a function that
exposes properties for The observed
metric most importantly the metric name
itself Imp in this case its value as
well as the element responsible for it
provided as a selector string by a
function in the link gist
now when you've got this field data and
you know which elements are responsible
for high interaction latency then it is
time to go to the lab and start testing
these interactions because it is lab
tools that will give you a bit more
insight into why interactions may be
slow
now one useful lab tool in Chrome Dev
tools starting in Chrome 106. we can now
rely on the performance profiler to show
interaction details right in a
performance Trace so say you know what
interacts or what element is causing
trouble you can test that in the
performance panel and dive right into
that interaction in the call Stacks
for example you can see in the
interactions area near the top of the
performance Trace panel there's an item
labeled interaction type click this
means that this interaction counts
towards inp and we can see that we have
a long task in our hand
um particularly on the The Click event
it appears and we can see that that that
click event is really running for a long
time
this method lets you dive right into
what's causing the delay during
processing and gives you some ideas for
how to break up or optimize that work
just a little bit better because this
particular long task quies causes quite
a bit of delay in the next frame being
presented and also can affect your inp
UT but if you want something a bit more
focused because the Chrome performance
profiler is kind of a it's kind of a
beast on its own it's a lot to take in
you can see interactions in the new
performance profiler in the performance
insights panel in Chrome Dev tools it's
a streamlined version of the performance
profiler we're all familiar with but a
bit easier to use
so you've profile an interaction and now
you want to know what you can do to
optimize it so what's next
the answer to this is rather complicated
and it depends on your website and for
after all every slow interaction has its
own fix but I'm hoping the following
provides you with a general framework or
strategy for getting your tasks under
control
so one good piece of advice developers
tend to follow is to split up work into
separate functions and we do this for a
number of reasons such as
maintainability readability and testing
it's easier to follow it's easier to
test and we get to isolate work into
separate little discrete functioning
units
however where JavaScript is concerned
uh because all the work item functions
from the previous code snippet are
executing in the same function the do
work function it will group all of that
work into a single long running task and
that's not great from a performance
standpoint because instead of five
little functions just doing all their
their own thing and all their own little
tasks you have a big old task that will
block the main thread from doing new
work including work that occurs because
of user interactions
this will affect your imp if users are
trying to interact with your website you
need to break this up
and one way to do that is to yield to
the main thread which breaks up tasks
now this is sort of a user land homemade
yielding function it uses a promise that
resolves with a call to set timeout and
this works because set timeout will
schedule its callback in a new task
now with that yield function you can
then yield to the main thread after
every little discrete piece of work by
awaiting the custom yield function
note you don't have to yield after every
function for example if you have
critical work that updates the UI you
can yield after those functions to give
the renderer a chance to do that work
the result instead is that you don't
have one giant task that has to run five
functions but a task for each separate
function and this gives the main thread
more opportunities to yield to other
things things like interactions or
background work that the user doesn't
necessarily see or care about
is this approach been hacky Maybe
but there could be a better solution in
the future
one proposed part of something called
the scheduler API is scheduler.yield
which will work much the same way as the
promise-based solution I've shown you
but will allow developers to tell the
browser directly if the current task
should be broken up and yield to the
main thread at specific points instead
of relying on hacks and I'm excited for
this potential addition to the web
platform as it will give developers a
way to break up work without user land
hacks
but I should take this time to remind
you
of one very important thing breaking up
work still isn't enough on its own imp
is all about time time it takes to
present the next frame if you have a ton
of little tasks that are running all the
time or lots of huge tasks that are
blocking the main thread you can't
present the next frame after a user
interacts with a page as fast as you
might need it to you still need to do as
little work as possible
another way of prioritizing user-facing
work is to explicitly yield to user
interactions with the is input pending
method
is input pending is available in
navigator.scheduling dot is input
pending and it returns a Boolean if the
user has interacted with an element on
the page at the time that it is called
in this code you can see how the do work
function adds separate functions to an
array of tasks and then within a while
loop this code checks to see if there is
a pending user input if so we explicitly
yield to the main thread so that
interaction can take place otherwise we
shift the next task off the front of the
tasks array and then we run it
the effective isn't input pending is
evident here we have a large blocking
task that do work kicks off however in
the middle of that task is input pending
is used to see if a pending user
interaction is waiting for the main
thread which in this case is brought on
by clicking a button to open a
navigation menu when is when is input
pending turns true we yield to that
interaction and allow the browser and
the main thread to handle it
but there is more that you can do and
that involves prioritizing tasks when
using this strategy you should think of
tasks in terms of what's critical and
user facing and wasn't in what isn't
visible or immediate
this figure shows how browser
prioritization works by default
when you leave things up to the browser
it will try to prioritize inputs based
on a system of internal priorities it
works pretty well but sometimes it needs
a little nudge
the post-task API currently only
supported in chromium browsers and
Firefox behind a flag adds more
flexibility to how browsers can schedule
work
most importantly it allows the developer
to schedule work based on a system of
three priorities the first is user
blocking which is for critical work that
must run at high priority
think of this priority as best for
interactions that need to be processed
as soon as possible there is user
visible which is for medium priority
work that may result in visual changes
to the user interface but maybe isn't
strictly critical
and then there is background which is
for low priority work think things like
analytics Collections and beaconing and
things that the user doesn't really see
or care about
so let's say you have a bunch of work
that doesn't result in any changes to
the user interface
this would be background work the shape
of the post task API allows you to
create task controller instances which
take a priority value using one of the
priorities I mentioned in the previous
slide then using the task controller's
signal property we can schedule work
using scheduler.post task according to
the task controller's priority
now let's say you run that work and then
the user interacts with the page to open
a navigation menu for example
the background work will run at lower
priority but if the user opens the
navigation menu those background tasks
will yield to that interaction
this is an exciting API
but even more exciting is that it's
still developing there are discussions
currently taking place about adding
finer grain priorities as well as other
mechanisms such as the scheduler.yield
functionality I mentioned earlier
on a final note I feel it's important to
make it clear that imp is a developing
metric the Chrome speed metrics team at
Google is still fine-tuning this metric
so some of what I said in this talk may
change but the fundamentals should still
hold true in the future
if you have any questions about imp feel
free to ask me in the hallway or at the
after party
I don't know everything but I'll try to
answer my you know to the best of my
ability I try my best
um but you you may stop me but I'll try
I will also tweet the link to my slide
soon which you will see shortly on my
Twitter profile at malkata that's
m-a-l-c-h-a-t-a
and with that thank you for your time
and hosting me in your incredible and
amazing City it's been both an honor and
an experience I'll always remember thank
you
[Applause]